WITH THAT.
BRET.
>> Bret: KEVIN THANK YOU.
A NEW BOOK FANNING THE FLAMES
WITH HER PRESIDENT TRUMP
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE FROM COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION.
THE GUARDIAN REPORTS, THE BOOKS
ARTHUR MICHAEL WEBB SAID ROBERT
MUELLER DRAWN UP AN INDICTMENT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT, THREE
COUNT INDICTMENT, BUT THAT IS
NOT WHAT MUELLER'S PEOPLE SAY.
IN THIS AUTHOR HAS BEEN COLD OUT
LIKE THIS BEFORE.
HERE IS FOX NEWS MEDIA ANALYST
AND MEDIA BUZZ, HOWARD KURTZ.
MICHAEL WITH HIS COMING OUT WITH
ANOTHER BOOK, MOST INFLAMMATORY
ALLEGATIONS HAS ALREADY BEEN
DENIED BY ROBERT MUELLER'S
OFFICE.
THE GUARDIAN, AND ADVANCED COPY
OF SIEGE TRUMP UNDER FIRE, --
"SIEGE: TRUMP UNDER FIRE" A
THREE COUNT OF OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE INDICTMENT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP DONALD TRUMP BEFORE
DECIDING TO SHELVE IT.
BUT PETER CARR TOLD THE
GUARDIAN, THE DOCUMENTS YOU
DESCRIBED DO NOT EXIST.
WOLFF WAS DOG BITE BY
CONTROVERSY BEFORE HE PUBLISHED
PREVIOUS BLOCKBUSTER FIRE AND "I
PREVIOUS BLOCKBUSTER FIRE AND "E
PREVIOUS BLOCKBUSTER FIRE AND "A
PREVIOUS BLOCKBUSTER FIRE AND "D
FURY" BACKSTABBING AND LEAKING
OF THE WHITE HOUSE BUT
POLITICIANS POINTED OUT NUMEROUS
ERRORS SUCH AS CNN PUBLISHED
PARTS OF THE SO-CALLED STEELE
DOSSIER WHEN IT WAS ACTUALLY
BUZZFEED.
THE PRESIDENT CALLED "FIRE AND
FURY" FULL OF LIES AND SAID HE
NEVER SPOKE TO WOLFF FOR THE
BOOK.
I ABSOLUTELY SPOKE TO THE
PRESIDENT WITH HER HE REALIZED
IT WAS AN INTERVIEW OR NOT.
>> THE FACT THAT THERE WAS A
CLAIM THAT THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
KNOW WHO JOHN BOEHNER WAS IS
PRETTY RIDICULOUS.
>> BOTH ACKNOWLEDGED THE BOOK IN
SEVERAL SOURCES GAVE HIM
ACCOUNTS THAT WERE BOLDLY UNTRUE
OR CONTRADICTED EACH OTHER, BUT
THAT HE PUBLISHED THEM ANYWAY.
IN A DIFFERENT CLASH OVER
CREDIBILITY, AND DRUMMER NYU
PROFESSOR IN "TIME" MAGAZINE
EDITOR AT LARGE TWEETED THIS
MADE UP QUOTE "PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN TOKYO, KIM JONG UN SLAUGHTER
AND WOULD MAKE A BETTER
PRESIDENT THAN SLEEPY JOE BIDEN"
AND AGREEING WITH THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR THAT BIDEN
HAS A LOW IQ AND DREW THIS
PRESIDENTIAL DENUNCIATION.
THIS IS WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
AGE OF FAKE NEWS.
PEOPLE THINK THEY CAN SAY
ANYTHING AND GET AWAY WITH IT.
HE WHO DEFENDED THE SATIRE BUT
KIND OF PLAUSIBLE NOW SAYS IT
WAS MEANT IN JEST.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEARER.
MY APOLOGIES.
SUCH INCIDENT GIVES MORE
AMMUNITION TO SLAM THE PRESS.